Khloe Kardashian giving fans a rare look
at her baby boy it's such a beautiful
thing the reality star shared this snap
with her kiddos over the weekend that's
Coco with her five-year-old daughter
true and nine-month-old son he's named
but I haven't announced it yet in the
snap we see her baby boy's profile as he
looks up to the side chewing on his
fingers rocking a red firefighter helmet
we all want to be cute over here okay
the pig was taken at Chloe's kids
cousin's party Kim Kardashian throwing
an over-the-top firefighter themed
fourth Birthday Bash for her son song
Happy Birthday to you
[Applause]
the celebration included a faux
Firehouse entrance murals of Psalm
dressed like a fireman fire balloons and
balloon sculptures that looked like
firefighters I don't know what's gonna
top that oh but there's more like a
firefighter Locker an epic dessert table
and Candy station a bounce house a ball
pit and slide and a DJ it's really fun
to see seemingly not in attendance was
Chloe's ex the father of her kids
Tristan Thompson even though the NBA
star has been getting a lot of love from
the Kardashian fam as of late they've
been big supporters of his recent move
to the Lakers sparking speculation from
fans that he and Chloe might be back on
I'm someone who I do like to put my
relationships as a priority and I tried
to make I really try to make that work
I've learned from experience it keeps
things close to your heart I don't know
things a little private is all mystery
is good in fact after Psalms bash Kim
posted this pick of Tristan playing in
Saturday night's matchup between the LA
Lakers and the Golden State Warriors on
her insta story why not Chloe interested
welcomed their second child together
back in August via surrogate I've been
on the fence about having Tristan come
to the hospital or not but this Tristan
wants to be here so I just figured why
not let him come I'll never get this
moment back the two split in 2021 after
Chloe learned that Tristan had fathered
a child with another woman news that
broke just days after their Embryo
transfer it's just so close I wouldn't
want anyone to think I did this after
the fact
why would I want to have a baby with
someone who's having a baby with
somebody else it was definitely very
angry and I think
feeling
Bamboozled I think that you have a real
insight into what's really happening
behind the scenes oh we'll be watching
for it as Chloe and Tristan's current
Dynamic is set to play out on season
three of Hulu's the Kardashians
premiering May 25th I wish I could tell
you this is going to be a mild relaxing
Serene season
it's not
[Music]